meet Imran a1 a1 was an 8 to 25 members
of the House Democratic caucus over the
past decade Alana and his family members
were paid some four million dollars by
House Democrats he was arrested on
charges of bank fraud yesterday while
attempting to flee the country he was
headed to Pakistan where he had
reportedly wired nearly three hundred
thousand dollars to himself
smashed hard drives were reportedly
found his home according to Politico
Alana and his wife had been investigated
for stealing equipment from some House
members their suspicions that a wand may
have put information from that equipment
onto the cloud while other House members
fired along months ago former DNC had
Debbie wasserman-schultz decided to keep
him on payroll until the day of his
arrest and attempted to stop the cops
from looking at her smashed laptop which
one apparently had naturally tough
Democrats are claiming that one may have
been arrested due to you guessed it
Islamophobia
all of which could raise some serious
questions question number one why was
one being paid so much money for so long
according to the Daily Caller Iran
wasn't even doing a good job in fact Kim
his team weren't on mandatory phone
calls they write fellow IT staffers the
DD CNF interviewed said the ones were
often absent from weekly meetings and
email exchanges one of the fellow
staffers said some of the computers the
Iran's managed were being used to
transfer data to an off-site server
second question what information did a
LAN transfer The Daily Caller which has
been all over this story reports that
Iran had quote access to all emails and
files of dozens of members of Congress
as well as the password to the iPad that
Debbie wasserman-schultz used for DNC
business before she resigned as its head
in July 2016 question number three what
does Wasserman Schultz trying to hide
not only then Wasserman Schultz keep
paying on until yesterday she reportedly
threatened the chief of the US Capitol
Police with consequences for holding
equipment that she says belongs to her
again here's the Daily Caller quote one
daily caller asked Wasserman Schultz on
Monday if it could inquire about her
strong desire for the laptop she said no
you may not
after the daily caller asked why she
wouldn't want the Capitol Police to have
any evidence they may need to find and
public punish any hackers of government
information she abruptly turned around
in the middle of a stairwell and
retreated back to the office from which
she had come forth question and final
question why aren't the media reporting
this story thus far only political among
the mainstream media news outlets has
covered the Elan story nothing from ABC
News nothing from NBC News calm nothing
from CNN
from the New York Times that is pretty
stunning considering the potential scope
of the story one suspicion our
mainstream outlets concerned that maybe
Iran might be in some way connected to
DNC leaks the damage Democrats or that
will do so in the future this is a major
major story we're just beginning to
learn the ramifications and it's
certainly weird at the very least that's
being buried by mainstream media outlets
i'm ben shapiro this is dementia Piro
show so that is the story that's on the
top of the conservative mind that it's
not the story the time on top of the
natural mind will get to president
Trump's announcement the transgenders
will now be banned from the military
we'll also get to John McCain's big
speech on the floor of the Senate
yesterday
we'll get to the latest on Trump care
all of it but before we do any of that I
first want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at rapper so there is
nothing more irritating in my life em I
promise you this when my wife loses her
phone or at least when she used to lose
her phone because now if you use his
cracker
she used to lose your phone like every
single day I mean we're at a movie one
time and she lost her phone in the
middle of the movie and she turns to me
in the middle of the film and she says I
can't find my phone
so for 45 minutes I'm grasping around in
the dark touching people's feet trying
to find her phone it is a source of
great irritation but thanks to tracker
we no longer have to do that I can say
honey just wait till the end of the
movie because I have this tracker right
on my keys the coin size device I hit it
and it actually rings through on the
phone even if the ringer is off and you
can use your phone to locate things in
your house by using the app on your
phone to locate your keys or your wallet
or other things you look at your child
if you've lost your child with the
tracker in their pocket do not actually
like get a piercing for the front but
you can attach it to your child's
clothing it is just it is a it is a
great device and and obviously it helps
you mostly with keys and wallet I'm just
joking about tracking people don't do it
in any case the fact is that a tracker
is the best advice for lost objects and
they have changed everything right now
they have something called the tracker
pixel it is the lightest Bluetooth
tracking device on the market it is the
again place it anywhere and it will help
you find it using your phone or if you
want to find your phone you can do it in
Reverse they have a 30-day money-back
guarantee which means you really have
nothing to lose go to tracker comm and
enter promo code Ben to get 20% off any
order that the tracker comm know at the
end is the tracker
komm promo code Ben for 20% off tra CK
are the tracker calm promo code Ben get
20% off your order and again it has made
my life and my marriage significantly
better so go over and check out dutch
record comedies that promo Clemenza they
know that we say okay so that democratic
story that the IT staffer who was caught
leaving the country after having wired a
bunch of money to Pakistan that's not
making the rounds anywhere in the
mainstream media and there are
suspicions that perhaps that's because
this was one of the sources for
WikiLeaks right this is unsubstantiated
so this is a speculation then maybe this
guy was actually taking all of that
information and funneling its WikiLeaks
and deputy Wasserman Schultz doesn't
want to let that cat out of the bag
because if the Democrats were to find
out that Russia didn't have to do with
this then it completely implodes their
entire narrative that again is total
speculation I don't tend to believe that
this guy looks more like a scamster who
was maybe blackmailing somebody like
debbie Wasserman Schultz I mean he was
again getting untold sums of money
Wasserman Schultz had hired until the
last five minutes I doubt that he has
anything's with WikiLeaks and we've had
no indications that he did so I would
put that conspiracy theory sort of on
the back burner until there's at least a
shred of evidence for any of that but it
is highly weird that the media are
ignoring it and it is even more weird
debbie Wasserman Schultz is trying to
kill an investigation into a guy who
apparently stole and smashed her laptop
so that's pretty weird stuff and that's
just weird stuff and we ought to keep an
eye on it okay in other news president
Trump has been on a rampage against Jeff
Sessions so this morning President from
seeking to distract from the Jeff
Sessions stuff and I think it's pretty
clear that's what he was trying to do he
tweets out that he wants to end the
policy that the Obama administration put
into place in June of last year that
would allow transgenders to serve openly
in the military it was a bad policy
because it made the entire army in the
entire military changes policies to
basically fit the needs of a very small
contingent of people who unfortunately
suffer from severe mental illness
suddenly you have women who are expected
to shower with men who say they're women
the military is expected to cover the
cost of transgender surgery and hormone
replacement and all the rest of it
that's something that has nothing to do
with military readiness and unlike race
which has no impact on military
readiness and ability to serve mental
illness has always been a four F issue
if you if you don't have a right to
serve in the Army no one has the right
to serve in the army and listen this is
not a rip on the patriotic transgendered
people who want to serve in the Army I
mean that's an amazing thing and good
for them they're making a sacrifice that
I was not willing to make so I have
nothing but praise for them but that
does not mean that the army that the
military has a responsibility to take in
people who at things are going to harm
unit cohesion destroy the ability of
people to get along in small areas under
lots of pressure and the ability of the
military to actually take a look but the
mental status is the people who are
attempting to enter like there are lots
of people who want to enter the military
or really out of shape and I'm sure the
military turns them away as well right
if you have flat feet you can be 4f so
then the military has lots of standards
you can't meet those standards and it
seems to me definitionally if you're a
man who thinks he's a woman you have a
mental illness that it's going to be
difficult for you to serve in the
military at the at the level that the
military would expect you to it creates
all sorts of issues also create
standards issues so let's say you're a
guy who's trying out the military but
you're transgender now so are you
expected to fulfill the female
requirement to the male requirements
because there are two different
requirements for women who are trying
out for the military versus men it's not
the same standard this is always the
question about women serving in combat
positions did they have to fulfill the
same rigorous physical standards as a
man right if you want a woman to be a
Navy SEAL I can have a lowered stand
refer to become a Navy SEAL having a man
who says is a woman now can he get the
female standard that's an issue of
people who have served on the frontlines
I have yet to meet a soldier who serves
on the frontlines who thinks the unit
cohesion will not be harmed by the
inclusion of transgender soldiers in on
the frontlines in battle areas and
combat areas and so in any case
president Trump is right on the policy
but how he rolled it out I think is
really not appropriate so he goes on
Twitter and as I think this is all a
distraction from sessions because within
five minutes he's tweeting about
sessions again he said after
consultation with my generals and
military experts please be advised the
US government will not accept or allow
transgender individuals to serve in any
capacity in the US military our military
must be focused on decisive and
overwhelming victory and cannot be
burdened with the tremendous medical
cost and disruption that transgender in
the military would entail thank you so
here is my problem with how President
Trump did this I think he made the right
call here and for this he deserves
praise it looks like a desperation move
to distract attention from the session
stuff that's what it looks like and the
reason I say this is because this was
not a well-timed well coordinated
rollout of an organized policy as I said
this morning
general mattis at the Department of
Defense should have been the leader on
this right he's in the middle like a
month
dog announced that there was going to be
a pause on the recruitment of
transgender troops and it ended a
six-month study on how it was going the
embedding of transgender troops in the
in the military and so we're going to
have a full study here's going to make a
full case for why transgenders in
military is not a good idea for morale
and unit cohesion and all the issues
that really matter on the battlefield
general mattis is the guy who should be
in charge of this effort in term sort of
Houston right I mean because the fact is
that if general mattis comes to terms
conclusion then he is the best advocate
for that it's very difficult for the
left to say the general mattis doesn't
take seriously military readiness it's a
lot easier for them to point to Trump
and say well you draft dodged and all
these people are braver than you are so
what are you doing saying they can't
serve in the military just from a
political points of view it doesn't make
a whole hell of a lot of sense for Trump
to just tweet this out it's also sort of
disrespectful to the transgender
individuals currently serving in the
military to just tweet out the policy
with no supportive details no
explanation of where this is going right
now the Department of Defense website
still has the old Obama policy on it
with regard to transgender individuals
so I'm glad the policy is apparently
changing but the Pentagon seems a little
bit bewildered by this it's not that
from never talked to mattis about it
apparently he has but it looks like the
Pentagon was taken by surprise by the
process like you don't tweet out major
policy decisions like this and then just
expect everybody to fall in line also
the timing really could not be much
worse because it looks like what Trump
is doing is picking on transgender
individuals in order to distract from a
session stuff at least that's have left
is going to play it and the timing is
even worse than that on this date this
date in 1948 was the date when President
Harry Truman integrated the military
racially so if you are trying to draw
the the perspective that that the
military should not be used for social
experimentation I would really prefer
from a PR standpoint that you not pick
the day that Harry Truman integrated the
military because obviously the Left
argument is going to be that integration
of the military originally is the same
as integrating the military in terms of
transgenders it's just the way this is
rolled out was once again nine hundred
eighty seven thousand degree wizard
underwater upside down mahjongg Hungry
Hungry Hippos wizard style I mean just
it doesn't make a whole hell of a lot of
sense the way this is rolled out except
that it's a big distraction it's not
distracting people though because it's
so obvious because within literally 40
minutes of Trump tweeting out this major
shift in American
it's very policy he's back to tweeting
about Jeff Sessions and this was the big
story of the day it continues to be the
big story of the day he tweeted this
morning quote why didn't Attorney
General Sessions replace acting FBI
director Andrew McCabe a Comey friend
who was in charge of Clinton
investigation but got big dollars
$700,000 for his wife's political run
from Hillary Clinton tour
representatives draining the swamp hey
mister president you are the president
you have the capacity to fire senator
sessions or attorney general sessions
and now you are in the position of
basically whining about something you
have power over he did it again today by
the way on Iran policy there's an
interview at The Wall Street Journal
where he said if it were up to me I
would have gotten out of the iran's in
180 days ago it is up to you well you
can stop whining on twitter now if you
want to do something about it do
something about it and the problem is
that Trump has sort of put his
credibility on the line here there's a
good case to be made when a president
makes a commitment like this when a
president goes after his own AG he's got
to follow through for credibility
reasons if you are a politician in the
Senate and Trump threatens you right now
are you going to take that threat
seriously it's hard to take the threat
seriously when he's out there
fulminating over Jeff Sessions but not
actually doing anything about it if you
are foreign adversary and you see
president Trump fulminating over his own
Attorney General but then in sort of
half-and-half ham-handed fashion trying
to get him to resign without doing
anything then you're thinking okay this
guy might be all bluster so listen I'm
not for him firing sessions I think
sessions should stay I don't think
sessions did anything wrong and I think
it is important to point out here then
not only did sessions not do anything
wrong when he recused himself but
sessions is recusal had nothing to do
with the special counsel the reason the
special counsel was appointed is because
President Trump fired James Comey
without any rhyme or reason except for
the Russia stuff which you then went on
national television and talked about and
in the process tried to hide behind a
letter written by sessions deputy right
rod Rosen seen the Deputy Attorney
General that force Rosenstein to recuse
himself and that's how you get the
special counsel not because sessions
recused himself Rosenstein was still in
place but Trump that rid of Rosen scheme
basically by watching it himself so
again using sessions as his sort of
whipping boy makes very little sense
right here and again if you want Trump
to have a successful presidency he needs
to rein it in he really truly needs to
rein it in so very
so yesterday Trump is speaking about
this on the campaign trail and you can
see that there's a rip that's beginning
to open in the conservative movement
which is actually a risk that I think is
overdue and worthwhile because one of
the questions that was going to be asked
throughout the Trump administration is
what can he do to alienate his base is
there anything Trump can do to alienate
his base are they really just so in love
with all of the fulminating about the
media are they so in love with the sort
of red meat that he throws his base
every so often that they are willing to
overlook the fact that he's not really
getting a lot of Policy done what does
he have to do in order to alienate them
it seems there are a lot of Trump fans
or alienated by the sessions thing which
I think is encouraging because their
standard may not be my standard in terms
of what they think Trump is doing wrong
but there is something that Trump could
do the Kanaly innate some of them so
Trump leads off last night by saying
aside from Lincoln he can be the most
presidential president ever who said
this during the campaign as well it's an
absurd statement here he is saying it
yesterday with the exception of the late
great Abraham Lincoln I can be more
presidential than any president that's
ever held this office that I kid doesn't
it's really okay it's real easy except
he's not doing it and he's spending his
days online watching TV like my
grandmother and then tweeting things out
not like my grandmother it's it's just
not good policy he came out yesterday
and again he continued to express anger
with sessions he said he disappointed me
AJ I am disappointed in the Attorney
General he should not have recused
himself almost immediately after he took
office and if he was going to recuse
himself he should have told me prior to
taking office and I would have quite
simply picked somebody else so I think
that's a bad thing not for the president
but for the presidency I think it's
unfair to the presidency and that's the
way I feel again it's not unfair to the
president for the AG to recuse himself
in a situation where it is politically
appropriate for him to recuse himself
and again sessions has nothing to do
with the appointment of the special
counsel right now it's pretty clear that
Trump wants to pressure sessions into
quitting so you can claim he didn't fire
sessions but everybody knows that he
wants sessions gone at this point I want
to talk a little bit more about this and
the reaction from the right and whether
Trump is susceptible to reason from
people
a quarter to his right because this is
going to be a good indicator for the
rest of his presidency talk about in
just a second but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at Birch
gold so right now a lot of people are
uncertain about the presidency about the
direction of the country about North
Korea about the economy there's too many
questions in the air which is why you
should have at least part of your
portfolio in precious metals Birch gold
helps you make that happen they will
give you a comprehensive 16-page kit
revealing how gold and silver can
protect your savings how you can legally
move your IRA or 401k out of risky
stocks and bonds and into a precious
metal IRA so if you get your note cost
and obligation case you go to
birchgold.com slash pen birchgold.com
slash pen again the countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau they're the people I
trust to invest in precious metals you
should trust them too
they're great people should ask all the
questions you want about investment and
then you should put at least part of
your portfolio in precious metals as a
hedge against inflation there's a report
today that the dollar looks like it's
beginning to weaken both has been up I
think several months in a row now so
investing in precious metals it's pretty
good time to invest in precious metals
and birchgold.com /ban can help make all
of that happen okay so what you're
seeing from the Trump administration is
that the people who are loyal is to
trump not the people who are policy
focused but the loyalists to Trump but
people whose job it is to make from look
good they keep saying sessions has to go
so Sarah how could be Sanders yesterday
she says I don't think that Trump's
issues with sessions are just going to
dissipate she doesn't think that this is
going to be glossed over and made better
in any real way he's continuing to move
forward and focus on other things but
that frustration certainly hasn't gone
away and I you know I don't think it
will okay and you're starting to see
some people even on Trump's right you
know people have been longtime fans of
Trump begin to lose faith with him on
the sessions thing I won't get to that
but for that I going to have to go over
to daily wire comm for a subscription
$9.99 a month and that means you can see
the rest of the show live it's not just
an audio show it is a video show as well
you can see my beautiful poem you can
see all the clips you can be part of the
mailbag live which we're going to be
doing on Friday it should be a great
mailbag since I'm testifying on the hill
tomorrow you can do all of that for
$9.99 a month plus you get our website
ad free you get to check out Andrew
Clayton's show live you get to check out
micromoles show god help us live and
I'll be launching it next Monday and if
you get an annual subscription you get
all of those things plus you get the
Magnificent left.this cheers hot or cold
or it is just the best thing that you
will ever experience in your entire life
you'll love it it is it is glorious in
every possible way you get that for free
when you get the annual subscription
we appreciate your listenership and if
you want to go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud just listen later then head
over there subscribe leave us a review
we are the largest conservative podcast
in the nation
[Music]
so I said for a long time that the
witness test there has to be some sort
of witness test for Trump it's one of
the reasons that I've respected for
example and Coulter's take on from more
than I've respected Breitbart News's
take on Trump at the general matter
because an actually has a standard it
may not be my standard again but it from
violates that standard she's willing to
say so so n wants her wall and if she
doesn't get her wall she's going to
tweet about it right she's going to say
I brought my wall and good for her good
for her if you elected Trump because you
wanted something he's not giving it to
you then you should say something about
it well finally it seems of sessions
there are a lot of people who are on the
Trump being right who are beginning to
lose a little bit of faith in Trump that
includes people like bring him some
bricks um yesterday he came out he said
listen Trump seems to have this bizarre
idea of what the AG is what the AG is is
definitely not a goalie I wonder if this
is a message that that agenda is you
know no longer opera I don't think so I
think I think the president has peculiar
concept of what the Attorney General's
job is he seems to think the Attorney
General is some kind of goalie for him
to protect him from you know whatever
may come his way from forces that he
finds animal-killing that's not the job
of the Attorney General it isn't the
Attorney General's job has always been a
little apart from other cabinet jobs the
Attorney General has to be the man who
enforces the nation's laws involving
everybody including the president okay
so britt hume is even saying okay don't
get rid of sessions tucker carlson who
has been full run on the Trump train he
comes out yesterday and he says listen
these attacks on sessions are nuts it's
completely a waste of time and effort
mr. president get back to work
it helps nobody with the partisans who
are pushing it so it's easy to
understand the frustration the president
feels but publicly attacking Jeff
Sessions for all of that that is nuts
senior White House staff thinks so too
they have asked the President to stop so
far without success meanwhile sessions
hasn't said a word okay so even this a
Tucker to is saying that there is a
breaking point Breitbart news yesterday
printed a story in which sent versus
Trump and attacks Trump for attacking
sessions cap you can and said sessions
deserves far better than the manner in
which he's being treated Gingrich says
the Trump should stop his attacks on
session so you're seeing virtually the
entire Trump being right and we see the
academic class
stated Trump this is something you can't
do and the reason you're seeing that is
because there is a group of people who
believe that Trump is going to be the
avatar for their policy they didn't just
select Trump to yell at things and
scream at TV and tweet silly things they
actually elected somebody because they
thought he can be he can do all those
things and that's great but he can also
be the avatar of our policy goals and
when Trump doesn't think that just not
only distract from that but undermine it
Jeff Sessions is a person who was on the
Trump train before anyone else I mean he
was the engineer on the Trump train this
is a guy who used the first senator to
endorse Trump in the primaries he was
the driving force behind Trump's
immigration policy which is probably
Trump's most popular policy with the
base getting rid of sessions is a huge
mistake for Trump we will see whether
Trump has painted himself into a box
here that is the big question has Trump
gone so far down this path that now he
can't afford to back off will he have to
fire sessions because he's come out so
obviously against sessions and is that
why he's trying to feed red meat to the
crowd with the transgender policy stuff
and mentioning how people will talk
about Merry Christmas again he's
basically going to revamp all of the old
Fox News talking points from five years
ago the war on Christmas kind of stuff
in order to pander to a particular crowd
to the Moonfire sessions Wow okay fine
but at least he said no transgenders in
the military that's what I'm not I'm
hoping that's not what happens here I'm
hoping that Trump pursues good policy
like the transgender policy that he is
pursuing in accordance with General
James natus who actually knows what he's
doing and that he lays off the sessions
and gets back to work because that's
what we need more of and Trump is
perfectly capable of doing this
so Trump is perfectly capable of doing
good things so do we have good Trump bad
form because you just did a bunch of bad
front but there's some good Trump here
so if we have good Trump bad Trump let's
play that as well which one will begin
okay so president Trump he's perfectly
capable of talking straight to the
American people when he wants to the
problem is he's so easily distractible
so yesterday he just speech in Ohio this
is where he is at his best I said for
months now that the White House should
basically just put Trump on tour they
should put him in Rust Belt areas
talking to people doing his speeches
enjoying himself here is Trump saying
that he's here to talk straight to the
American people this is he stick this is
where he should live he should never
move off of this we have spent the
entire week celebrating with the
hard-working men and women who are
helping us make America great again I'm
here this evening to cut through the
fake news filter and to speak straight
to the American people
okay so this is where Trump is at his
best and you know he has these moments
that are great so there's a protester we
showed up at one of his protests with a
with a hammer and sickle and here is
Trump just mocking the crap out of him
deservedly
[Applause]
well he's a young one he's gone back
home to mommy Oh is he in trouble he's
in trouble he's in trouble and I'll bet
his mommy voted for us right know what I
mean that's where Trump is at his best
if he paired that with natural policy
prescriptions then he'd be golden
because Trump is great at that part of
this he is great at that part of this
but he needs to actually get back to
that part of this and stop focusing so
much on these loyalty tests I mean you
remember that supposedly he asked FBI
director James Comey but before he
appointed him would he get his loyalty
and then he denied later that he asked
Comey for his loyalty is there any doubt
at this point that he has coming for his
loyalty is there any doubt I mean he's
going out there he spent the last week
saying the Jeff Sessions isn't oil to
him Jeff Sessions is the most loyal to
him and he's out there questioning his
loyalty it's very difficult to claim
that Trump isn't motivated by loyalty to
him above all he needs to get beyond
that he needs to be bigger than that
he's the president of the damn United
States for goodness sake for goodness
sake and most powerful men honor
get over your issues and start working
for the American people meanwhile
speaking with people who are not working
for the American people the United
States Senate is right now looking at a
bunch of options on health care they
passed the the motion to proceed that
was basically an ad 51 votes to consider
the House bill on Obamacare revision I'm
not going to call it repeal in a place
because it isn't it was Obamacare
revision they had this vote to proceed
on it that didn't mean a vote to pass it
that meant to proceed to debate they got
51 votes and protesters from the left
being the idiots that they are they
immediately started chanting to kill the
bill there's only one problem no one
knows what the bill is so they presented
at the brca the House version of the
bill last night it went down some
flaming defeat nine Republicans voted
against it showing once again that
Republicans don't actually want to touch
Obamacare and the protesters were
chanting kill the bill there have been
like five different bills that are being
presented we still don't know the final
text of the bill so it's kind of weird
for them to chant this but there you are
[Applause]
sargent arms will restore order in the
chamber okay meanwhile Mitch McConnell
is saying that you know this is a vote
to open debate we're finally going to
get to this open debate guys for seven
years you should have been having this
debate I don't know what you were doing
for nearly the last third of my life
what were you doing you're just sitting
around bitching about Obama I get it
it's fun but at some point you have
figured out what you're going to do so
here's Mitch McConnell you know
championing the idea that we've finally
open debate yeah we've open debate you
have a majority in this chamber you
should have been able to do this pretty
easily they didn't send us here just to
do the easy stuff they expect us to
tackle the big problems and obviously we
can't get an outcome if we don't start
the debate and that's what the motion to
proceed is all about many of us on this
side of the aisle have waited four years
for this opportunity and thought it
would probably never come some of us
were a little surprised by the election
last year and so I can't put too much of
this audio lest everyone drive off the
road if you're listening and burst into
fiery flame the boredom from listening
to Mitch McConnell I mean thatthat dude
he has a gift he has a gift if we could
somehow bottle his charisma into pill
form it would cure insomnia for for
millions in any case the big news that
came out of the speeches yesterday was
John McCain
McCain comes back to the chamber you
know grouchy old John McCain grisly old
John McCain he comes back to the chamber
after you know being diagnosed with
brain cancer big scar over his eye
because they had to carve into him they
get rid of some of this I mean it's
amazing that he came back and he shows
up and he gives a speech and this is
widely hailed on both the left and the
right is sort of be the final cry of the
lion now I think that McCain would help
of God should be around for some time to
come you know all prayers with him but
he's getting a lot of praise for the
speech on the left they were angry at
the speech because he was saying we
should return to regular order we need
some sort of bipartisanship and then he
voted in favor of the motion to proceed
to the left was saying well if you want
bipartisanship why are you voting on a
motion to proceed to move forward
and the right was saying but in the same
speech she said he's not going to vote
for the actual bill so if you're not
gonna vote for the actual bill why vote
on the motion to proceed you already
have two Republicans Lisa Murkowski and
Susan Collins say they won't vote for
any underlying bill which means
basically all this stuff is do I in any
case McCain gave the speech and a lot of
people are celebrating it I did not like
the speech I did not like the speech
from McCain and I didn't like it for a
variety of reasons there was one thing I
liked about it and there were a bunch of
things that I didn't McCain is one of
these people who believes he's like John
Roberts on the Supreme Court he believes
in the prestige of the institution the
magic of the Senate you know John
Roberts felt this about the Supreme
Court which is why he supposedly ruled
the way he did in the Obamacare case and
I don't want to undermine the prestige
of the court as a as a as a body that's
above politics so what I'm going to do
is I'm gonna make it totally political
and I'm gonna rewrite law from a bunch
John McCain does some of that same stuff
yet over the prestige of descended a
collegial body where we get together and
we discuss the issues on a higher level
while ignoring all of the noise from
outside I hate this garbage I hate this
garbage because it's both disingenuous
and it's a losing strategy and then in
case you start off with the stuff that I
like he talks about look we're a
co-equal branch of government we are not
Donald Trump subordinates and that means
that we should pass policies that we
think are beneficial for the country
this part is true here's McCain
yesterday this place is important the
work we do is important our strings
rules and seemingly eccentric practices
that slow our proceedings and insist on
our cooperation are important our
founders envisioned the Senate as the
more deliberative careful body that
operates at a greater distance than the
other body from the public passions of
the hour we are an important check on
the powers of the executive our consent
is necessary for the President to
appoint jurors in powerful government
officials and in many respects to
conduct foreign policy whether or not we
are of the same party we are not the
presence of ordnance
we are his equal okay that's all fine
that's all fine but then here is it but
then here's the part that's it that's
the problem because she does two things
that are a problem he calls for a return
to regular order regular order means
that you're not going to use
reconciliation or to pass things you're
actually going to gather a
filibuster-proof majority in order to
move
things to debate and that would probably
require bipartisan consensus so he calls
for this yesterday here's a reset our
system doesn't depend on our nobility it
accounts for our imperfections and gives
us in order to our individual strivings
that has helped make ours the most
powerful and prosperous society on earth
it is our responsibility to preserve
that even when it requires us to do
something less satisfying than winning
ok so then and then he finishes up by
bashing talk radio because this is John
McCain's thing he has to be above it all
he bashes talk radio of course hope we
can again rely on humility on our need
to cooperate on our dependence on each
other to learn how to trust each other
again and by so doing better serve the
people who elected us stop listening to
the bombastic loudmouths on the radio
and television and the internet to hell
with them ok I think it's applause from
the chamber of course stop listening to
all those young guns were in their cars
and on their phones using the telephone
errs and the info webs ok here's my
problem with all this number one
Democrats don't play by the rules with
this with regard to this kind of stuff
in 2005 Donald Dunn and John McCain in
2005 worked with Democrats to avoid
democratic filibuster so Democrats
filibustered a bunch of Bush judicial
nominees you recall this and in doing so
John McCain put together what they
called the gang of 14 and they made a
deal with a bunch of Democrats that
certain judicial nominees would go
through and certain judicial nominees
would not but they wouldn't use the
filibuster in order to shut down the
process it was unprecedented to use the
filibuster to shut down judicial
nominees before at this point
great for John McCain bipartisan
solution look at that bipartisanship
returning to regular order okay in 2010
the Democrats are short votes on
Obamacare and they are tempting through
a bunch of procedural manipulations to
ram through their agenda and John McCain
approaches the Democrats this time the
Republicans are in the minority in the
Senate so in 2005 they're in the
majority in 2010 they're in the minority
and John McCain goes to the Democrats
and he says I would like a new gang of
14 let's put the other gang of 14 and
we'll get together and we'll hash out
some compromises on health care that
we're able to proceed with and the
Democrats
turn to John mechanical you go screw
yourself it returned to regular order is
only a thing if
Democrats are willing to work with you
Democrats are not willing to work with
Republicans and they are willing to bend
the rules and break them which means
that the rules themselves no longer
apply when it comes to these sorts of
niceties listen I would prefer that we
had bipartisanship in the Senate too I
would prefer a lot of things I prefer
that every senator where Ted Cruz and
Mike Lee look-alikes right I prefer the
Ben Sasse where the chair of the Senate
for a lot of things I prefer that
unicorn's we're able to power our cars
with their magic poop lots of things I
wish but John McCain's wish for what the
Senate should be is not what the Senate
is and when John McCain says stop
listening to those bombastic loudmouth
on talk radio it's those bombastic loud
mouths on talk radio that one your party
a majority and ensure that Obamacare
repeal stays on the table and doesn't
allow you guys to get away with crappy
compromises that end up compromising the
promises that you made I'm getting kind
of tired of this elitist and this is
elitism this in me just routine well we
in the Senate we know better don't
listen to those people who elected us
the people who elected you are the ones
who listen to those of us who actually
speak about politics for a living
because we care enough to try and tell
our audience is what's happening so you
know I all best wishes to John McCain I
appreciate that he has a lot of respect
for the processes of government he needs
to live in the real world with regard to
this stuff and stop trying to pretend
the Senate is something it's not more
than anything stop trying to pretend
Democrats are something they aren't okay
before I get the things I like and
things I hate first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at the US
concealed-carry Association so you're in
your house middle of the night you hear
somebody with a crowbar at the front
door the person is trying to crowbar
open your front door you grab your gun
you rush out person come through the
door and you shoot them end of the story
right you're the hero not the end of the
story the police are going to come
they're going to arrest you in all
likelihood they're going to question you
it's going to take years of your life to
get out from under the burden of having
fired a shot even in self-defense even
in your own home that is what the u.s.
CCA is for they educate you they train
you they make sure that you're legally
and financially protected for after you
pull the trigger
in honor of July 4th they're also making
sure that you're able to get guns if
you're a responsible American they're
doing the great American giveaway they
want my listeners to be some of the
people to know about it right now five
chances to win 1776 dollars worth of
guns and ammo of your choice 1776 yeah
that's a lot of money toward guns and
ammo of your choice you can register to
win over it defend my family now.com
defend my family now.com again you
should sign up with us CCA anyway
because they provide you all the
resources you need in terms of education
but also after you pull the trigger but
you also have a chance five chances
actually to win almost $2,000 776
dollars for the guns and ammo of your
choice which is awesome defend my family
now.com defend my family now calm go and
check it out there is no right more
important than the right to keep in
their arms and there is no group that is
better dedicated to helping you achieve
that right than the UFC CA go over to
defend my family now calm and and go
register and and let them know that we
sent you as well okay time for some
things I like things I hate another
Bible so things I like this week we are
doing music that is featured in movies
so yesterday we did yesterday we did
Samuel Barber's Adagio for Strings which
of course is in platoon Lawrence Doyle
this is another piece of music that you
will all recognize but some people don't
know what it is this is Strauss is Blue
Danube Waltz you'll remember it from
2001 a Space Odyssey when there is a
three-hour shot of a turning spaceship
and here is the Blue Danube Waltz
[Music]
so great piece of course everybody knows
this piece has been used in cartoons all
over the place
a great story about this composed in
1866 and Strauss his stepdaughter
wouldn't met johannes brahms who is
actually one of the nicer composers a
lot of composers are jerks Brahms was
not when he signed something for her he
wrote down the first few bars of the
Blue Danube Waltz
and then he wrote down a last knot by
Brahms under and underneath that was his
autograph on the on the on the piece of
paper so great piece okay a quick thing
I hate will do that okay so Van Jones is
is the one thing that drives me
absolutely up a wall and we talked about
this a little bit yesterday is the
attempt to infuse politics into every
aspect of pop culture the one that
drives me the most nuts is just using
politics into sports sports is just a
competition
leave me alone I want to see somebody
hit a ball or shoot a ball or hit
somebody in the face that's all I want
from from my sports man John says
athletes should be more political no for
the love of God they shouldn't here's
Van Jones saying this do you think
athletes should be more vocal than they
of course on both sides on all issues
and I'll tell you why the number one
rare thing in the world right now it's
not it's not money I mean there's money
all over the places I don't have enough
you don't have enough it's all over the
place it's time its attention the
richest people I know are still time
poor so if somebody has attention if
they're famous they have the most
valuable commodity in the world if you
can use that to make the world better
you should and part of the problem I see
now is people are saying I'm not going
to speak out who these great issues that
are going on bad things happening that
I'm not going to speak out because I
want to protect my paycheck that's very
inspiring sir we're going to put that on
your tombstone like said nothing but
they don't have to speak out okay the
idea that athletes job is to speak out
but since you want to speak out more
power to you but the idea that athletes
are in a unique position to speak out
know if you're in a unique position to
speak I should know something about it
this does not mean that every athlete is
dummy there's some athletes who actually
know something about the policies upon
which case they expound but the fact is
the vast majority of athletes are not
people who are in their position because
of their grand
knowledge of budgetary process okay when
Muhammad Ali was mouthing off about
politics it was not because he was
widely knowledgeable about politics in
the United States most of what he was
saying was wrong and Bentham by the
nature of Islam the idea that that
athletes on a routine basis are saying
intelligent things is just silly and it
demeans our culture you want to know how
you got Donald Trump as president
lefties it's because of this you merged
culture and politics and then you're
surprised when a cultural figure becomes
a politician and wins everything okay so
before we leave quick Bible mode so
we've gone through all of the various
parts of the of the Old Testament and
now we've been doing parts of the
prophets and the writings and it
corresponds to the Old Testament so one
of the pieces that we read this week is
from the Book of Isaiah and there's a
one particular verse from the Book of
Isaiah that I wanted that I want to
point out and that is from chapter 1 the
very beginning says the vision of Isaiah
the son of a mosquito concerning Judah
and Jerusalem in the days of Lucia and
says hear o heavens and give ear o earth
for the Lord has spoken
children I have raised and exalted yet
they have rebelled against me so what
does it mean they have the heavens in
the earth actually testify against a
people right I mean they're not living
things how can you have them testify and
the idea is that God created the world
for a purpose he created the world for
the purpose of man and created the world
as a testimony to man and this is why
man's man's control of nature is so
unbelievably beyond anything else that
you find in the animal kingdom because
he created our minds in accordance with
his he created our ability to shape the
world around us in accordance with his
will he also give us the power to
destroy and what we do with the world
around us is going to be the testimony
against us so this is not an
environmentalist call never to cut down
a tree but is a suggestion that if we do
not do the right things then the earth
itself will be testimony against us for
having done the wrong things because if
the earth was only created in order to
help us be better to one another and
fulfill God's mission then our failure
to do so will will basically disown the
reason for Earth's creation in the first
place you know earth is not the center
of the universe obviously but we are the
center of God's universe and that's what
makes it he and he loves us so that he
placed us in a place that we had the
capacity to control the the elements
around us if we fail to do that in
proper fashion if we fail to use our
powers for
then the existence of the universe
essentially becomes meaningless in the
religious point of view
okay so we'll be back tomorrow I'll be
testifying from Washington DC so I'll
give you the update on how it went on
the hill I'll be testifying about
colleges and crackdowns on free speech
if you're over near the hill feel free
to show up I believe it's open to the
public we will talk to you tomorrow I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the venture Pierrot
show
[Music]